good morning today we are on another on
another family adventure we are going to
visit this locals gem called
um Spring Mountain Ranch and I always
don't like when I hear stuff like that
we're like oh Vegas is local secret
um because I'm like well it's not a
secret anymore don't do that but I saw
it on Instagram so I'm like nosy and I
wanted to check it out so we are on our
way to Spring Mountain Ranch however
since it's early in the morning we
wanted to get some grub and near Spring
Mountain Ranch this is all these Papa's
idea whenever we go do something new he
likes to eat in that area just to kind
of see what that little area or corner
of the city or that town is about and
I'm happy he did that because we just
had breakfast at this little Nook spot
called Cottonwood station
and it was super CUNY and I'll tell you
why start driving around Papa
yes ma'am because around here it's dead
like there's nothing here there's
nothing but uh mountains and just like
plain land and then I don't know where
it pops up this town that we're driving
in so we're gonna explore it together
look at this there's so many massive
thick tall old trees which tells you
look at that dog he's just chilling
like it's such a CUNY little town like I
think this is their only Elementary
School here yeah and there's like a
swimming pool like a City swimming pool
there was like a tiny little Library
when I say City I think this whole town
fits on a football field like it is
small like like there's probably only 20
houses yeah on the way it's just all
desert and rocks and mountains and then
out of nowhere you see this little Oasis
of a town that's not even far from Vegas
it's only like 10-15 minutes away but
it's it's so small and quaint check this
out
how cute is this yeah it's like all of a
sudden you're in like big bear or
something
and maybe if you like live here the
whole time oh look at that you're
probably like oh it gets boring really
fast but someone like me everyone has a
golf cart that but someone like me I
love this you think it's cool oh that's
like a pretty modern house behind that
lady
yeah but it looks like that like it'll
just be mountains that's a new house
there was a more modern house on the
other side
Mischief Night huh
oh this is pretty
oh no this is a big old modern house
with the RV there it is
a big house
there's another golf cart that golf cart
light I love the golf club look at this
really pretty wow
howdy
look at that smile what a great lady
there's another random dog and what's
cute is this town is so small you know
every dog belongs to there's another dog
I think that guy has three legs
okay hold on these tugs dogs tend to
want to just jump around in the car yeah
no or go underneath your car hey doggy
you see him yeah right there okay yeah
he's right there a little orange dog
okay oh look look he's in the back now
you see him back there no we can't see
him move forward a little bit you see
him behind you monks you see him right
there but then behind you oh yeah
mama I
thought the dog has three legs yeah the
white one there's another dog
yeah yep see and it's like it looks like
that that's the end of it yeah this is
the border and then out there is just
what you normally see a Vegas desert and
in here it's just its own town
really cool
he doesn't seem sad he seemed pretty
happy
oh look at that they just hang out
outside with no bugs tiger will go on
forever
now this one is beautiful look at that
this looks like one of those like Joshua
Tree like Desert Oasis Escape homes this
is beautiful there's the golf cart life
this is where their dog poops for sure
here's the whole pile right there done
another one another one another one
that looks beautiful too
wow this is really pretty wow look at
all that wood look at this this is the
log cabin
beautiful
Log Cabin like this
they didn't have a nest camera though no
I definitely did oh there's that RV back
there you see that oh yeah they know how
to live the good life out here
another golf cart
I know I want one I think we need to get
one
all right so this is what we were
talking about you come down this road on
this side it's just all desert that's
what we're used to right red rock is
over there and we're coming down here
all of a sudden there's this random town
full of greenery and we're like okay we
had to check it out inside and it just
so happened that there was like a little
breakfast buffet I mean that Buffet Cafe
that had really good reviews almost like
400 reviews
uh four and a half Stars it's called
Cottonwood station where we ate at
really really cool all right there it is
Spring Mountain Ranch State Park a
Local's best kept secret
so they say
what do we what do we got what do we got
what do we got there's apparently a lake
in here oh really
that's a name you don't hear anymore
Harriet
that's true oh roller coaster put your
hands up
CUNY guy
pretty
kid fire danger hi
why why why why why is it high today why
is it high why is that why why warm
today
no drones bro
oh no move up more or something because
you're or back more yeah because there's
a baby and it's blocking right by the
there we go look what we see a baby
shark
look monkey you see that baby donkey
over there
and there's another guy oh there's a lot
of them there's that guy there's another
guy behind him over there how cool is
that oh he's eating I want to eat some
food
take a picture oh my goodness my heart's
about to explode
Mia Mia's like ooh
no
no papa what look out your window here
take the camera with you
like this candy baby donkeys
and they're wild
ah and they're furry they're very baby
donkeys and they're real they're statues
no they're statues that are moving
I'm just kidding no they're real look at
them that is so cool
it's a wild burross
what's so funny about that no they're
wild Burros that's really how you call
them that's a pretty name
low
this
so we're now walking inside
don't know where we're going there
by just trying to explore
it's like it has his toys
so pretty look at that house
not sure what that is
it looks so peaceful look at the dead
and the baby
yay
oh my goodness
cow spotting
no that's why they put it here do I have
been here or it's not supposed to look
at them
so there's like a bunch of trails
but I'm like so confused as to how to
like read this map
because I'm like where the are we
how do we get there what does the pink
mean okay pink means okay oh the okay so
it all kind of loops around huh
I don't know
we'll just get lost and see what happens
so we set up camp
that guy's playing baseball
yeah is exploring there's a bunch of
Critters in here
you hear him
you hear that
creepy or maybe not creepy I'm just not
used to the outdoors but this is
wonderful this is wonderful
gonna go again
ready keep it on the ball
you did a good job on that one here we
go
Mia come
Mia
good girl that's it see you later
so the street is right there however
we are over here yeah because my dad my
dad said you want me to go over to the
show and guess what he said yes see
if the sun says it then the dad does it
I hope you get a ticket that's how it
works
that's so mean I don't want to go over
that please I'm not gonna go over that
I'm gonna go to the side like this as a
smart driver oh my God
we're just gonna die We're Not Gonna Die
you told him to do it
actually I was actually going you said
yes yeah so of course there are five I'm
gonna listen to you because you know
better
so we just woke up from a nap but while
I was napping
I love the day and age that I
live in I love it and I hate it this is
the reason why I love it I love it
because I'm able to shop in my sleep we
just did uh what is it uh what is it
called instacart run to Costco Costco's
of all things
is the worst on the weekend and the week
is the only time I can go get it so I
opted for instacart
and hook it
we got all of our groceries in Papa
opted
to get top soreline because he's in a
he's on a cut and why get this why get
it from Costco so Costco actually has
really high quality meat and it's cheap
look at this I got one two three four
five six of them for 40 bucks oh would
it cost that like in Albertsons what if
you go to a butcher shop is it even
cheaper uh depends because now you're
you're talking about super high grade
and then it's hard to mass meal prep you
know I see but this is like what let's
see so it's nine bucks a pound probably
like 10 to 15 bucks a pound
that's what I'm talking about so you got
that and then you got a flank because
these are both low and fat
it's hard to even find Cuts like this at
a normal
um damn all right Kirkland Costco
so this thing
this is what I always forget about
Costco is one it's always cheap and two
because it's so cheap you can go
overboard really really fast and then
you look at your cranking like I didn't
even buy that much how the did I
spend so much so check out what I bought
Okay so this and this you can do the
math right 40 and 40.
we've got some trash bags I looted in by
that much I didn't buy that much
pressure about
I got paper towels bathroom tissue and
not even name brand I mean unless you
consider Kirkland in England but like
nothing outside of Kirkland okay
oh my God softener
dishwash soap
Tampax okay that's probably a name brand
Dove deodorant because obvious melon
okay this because
once I knew they invented this the
I get a sponge you know the ones that
use it with their hand the girl I got my
hold up has that mildewy smell literally
after a week like am I doing something
wrong I don't know but I just opted for
this this is a this was a Splurge
for sure
fabric softener cold brew still Kirkland
come on bruh still Kirkland but these
are blonde Tyga's favorite splurge
the most Asian ever
look at Aloha soy sauce Papa
that's one thing you can ever have too
much of
um
tampons
um yes fabric washer whatever detergent
Fairlife bruh look at this 30 grams of
protein
zero fat I believe I can't remember I
like the nutrients but dude so worth it
water
take his favorite have you ever seen the
theme here I thought
this raisin bread potato
cinnamon Cheerios for taika this one's
for Papa
for inside outside I mean from the
garage into inside the house you can
rub your feet and then I got this
because we have a water softener system
so I got two of it
how much you spent
guess how much I spent if I hadn't told
you
if I hadn't told you how much I'd spent
how much why don't you just cut it now
okay Tyga
because I don't want to
so you're gonna save it
what the are you saying anyway
not enough
and not at all anything okay if I hadn't
told you how much I spent how much would
you think I spent I have an idea
whatever
yeah it's our water softener system
there's a lot of stuff okay well how
much do you think
oh God damn tiger
how much
just get if you didn't know
this would you would have guessed
I told you I kept telling you I can't
believe I spent that much
[Applause]
with the face for the sake of the video
I'm gonna make it way bigger wait this
is way cheaper no what if it's cheaper
and I'm like I can't believe I spent
that much
are like two three hundred shut the
up way less than this
probably a thousand because or 900
because my normal groceries are two to
three hundred bucks and it's only like a
third of this I don't buy salt cream
like two bags of salt crystals that was
only six dollars though five paper
towels like that size I never buy
you know I never buy the jumbo piece so
you don't buy the that we normally
use yeah
yeah well I spent 500 bucks
get the hell out of here
I'm just tell you
all right YouTube
[Applause]
these guys are watching Bruce Lee
Enter the Dragon
this is one of the few and rare movies
that Tycho will sit through and is
absolutely
entranced by the martial arts I don't
know if you understand the storyline but
just the good guys and bad guys he just
is of it absolutely Frozen and in full
attention he won't sit through that
or like that for many other ones also
this is his second bowl of his boom
Chicka Pop
sweet and salted kettle corn
this one is so bomb if you haven't tried
it
I highly recommend you try it at first I
was kind of like skeptical I was like ah
it's just a packaging that's really cute
it shouldn't be that good and I don't
know why maybe the packaging got me and
I ended up buying it anyway and then
after I had I was like God damn
this is rather
scrumptilly delicious
kept trying to do this with one hand
I'm again goddamn ass oh Jesus Christ
with stove
about stuff like that falling on the
floor
yeah we'll eat it one of those many good
things
I think a dog
our favorite part of Sunday isn't it I'm
gonna go to sleep isn't it
isn't it isn't it everyone's favorite
part of a Sunday
cleaning your chonies and folding them
I don't mind the washing part because
technically I'm not washing it I just
put it in the washer and the washer does
all the work that's my favorite part you
know what I mean it's now taking it out
and focusable to get another type of
person that has to fold it the moment I
take it out of the dryer because we all
know and if you don't know this I'm
about to school you on it we all know
that when you leave it sitting there
crunched up like this it only creases
and it's not like a minor crease it's
like a deep hateful crease that it
creates in your clothes and then you're
just like man I either have to wash
it again to get the creases out or I
have to iron in I don't know anyone that
irons these days so there you go
washing it all over again when you
should have just folded it the moment it
came out so this is how Papa and I flirt
these days we're probably gonna like go
grab the same garment and then we're
gonna hold hands and then we're gonna be
like oh no you feel that way no I think
it's our Suns yeah and then we go oh
and then we look at each other for a
little bit and take a little bit of love
and then we go and then we keep folding
because we're trying to get to bed it's
almost nine o'clock
everyone knows Bart's bedtime is 10 mine
has changed to like nine o'clock now so
it's almost gonna be my bedtime
so we gotta fold this fast okay
okay on that note but as much as good
night love you very much see you
tomorrow hey Mia say bye
thank you
perfect